Joe Thomas NFL Network analyst he now
gets to put on a suit and tie
Wisconsin grad as Badgers go against
Ohio State that might not be pretty
Joe is NFL Network analyst and you can
see him tonight it'll be 6:00 Eastern
starting with the Bears and the Cowboys
good morning Joe how are you good
morning I was doing better until you
took that little dig at my badgers as if
past performance as any indication on
future results I still think the Badgers
have a great chance to win on Saturday
well what's that mean a great channeling
are you willing to put something on the
line
Wisconsin alumni and I'm gonna cheer for
my team no matter what the expected
results are okay all right I mean I was
willing to put something III have Carson
Palmer's Heisman Trophy that he sent me
I will put that up against your how
about your Hall of Fame your Hall of
Fame jacket that you'll get one do you
want to talk about your Browns now or at
the end of this conversation okay has
Freddie kitchens done enough to keep his
job well it's really going to come down
to these last four games of the season
obviously they have greatly not lived up
to expectations and so right now it's
not looking very good for Freddie when
you have the amount of talent today I'm
on offense to have a quarterback like
Baker Mayfield readdress and not be able
to score points the way they have
struggled to score points is even it's
not a good look and obviously I think
they really have to finish this season
strong and put together a case for
Freddie kitchens that says you know I
made a lot of mistakes in my first year
as a head coach but I was able to
improve in the last quarter of the
season and they can see that he's headed
in the right direction as a head coach
if he's not able to do that it's going
to be a tough sell for him to have them
to bring it back I look at a couple of
situations here Joe like Dallas Dallas
is in that great position you feel like
a better coach a different coach comes
in that's a Super Bowl that you have
Super Bowl Talent on that team
even has this window of opportunity with
two good running backs you've got young
talent on the defensive side of the ball
line could be better you have a young
quarterback and you have some talented
wide receivers you don't want to miss
this opportunity because you don't know
when it'll happen again and I see the
Browns and Cowboys their ownership
probably looking at this the same way
and saying you know we need to bring it
we don't have the right person in in
either one of these jobs do you think
you're you're exactly right that's why
the pressure is so high right now on the
Haslam's to be able to get the coaching
position correct right now and that's
why these last four games are so crucial
because like you mentioned right now
they've got Baker on the rookie deal
they've got incredible talent for a lot
of different reasons that you mentioned
specifically at the running back
position being able to get kareem hunt
really cheap because of what happened
with his situation and then having Nick
Chubb on a rookie deal I mean they're
full of young talent which is great
because they were able to get all these
good players under the salary cap but
that only lasts our so long you know
these guys come up for free agency
you're gonna have to pay them and a lot
of those names aren't going to be on the
team so this is definitely their window
if they want to make that run former
Browns all-pro tackle Joe Thomas joining
us he'll be part of NFL network's
coverage tonight Bears Cowboys
if the Cowboys lose finish that sentence
to me it's an if-then proposition right
now for Jason Garrett because it's going
to be if they can win the division and
get into the playoffs then he's able to
keep his job depending on how the team
does in the playoffs if they're not able
to make the playoffs then he gets fired
absolutely if they make the playoffs and
lose right away he gets fired but if
they can go on a run in the playoffs I
think there's enough for Jerry Jones to
say let's bring him back so tonight's
game is important for the playoff race
but they're still in command because the
NFC East is so bad that even if they
lose tonight they can still win the last
three and make playoffs yeah it's still
it's it's it's odd because you just had
Ron Rivera being fired and now Jerry if
they would lose tonight and then you
have that long I'm you know it's not
like you're losing it on a Sunday and
then the following submit so you're
losing on a Thursday and then you have
all of that time
and that's where I I would get a little
nervous if I was Jason Garrett if they
lose tonight because it feels like the
longer Jerry thinks about it the worse
it gets the more he wants to talk about
it and I just wonder if a Thursday night
loss is different than a loss on Sunday
yeah you're right he does have a little
bit more time especially because a lot
of people won't be in the building as
weekend seriously after a Thursday game
NFL players and coaches will get a
Saturday Sunday off before they're back
in the building on Monday but I do think
that if piri Jones is making this
decision in a bubble you know he
possibly would make a decision to get
rid of Jason if they lose but I think
he's got enough people around him that
he respects right now especially his son
Steven Jones said they feel like truly
what they want to do is give Jason here
this season to give him one last
opportunity to prove his case that he
can take this team to the heights that
they feel like the talent should be able
to take this team to and by firing him
right now
they always would have that little thing
in the back of their mind going well
maybe if we wouldn't have fired him we
could have won the division and we could
have gone on a run the playoffs because
we've heard it I mean there's a reason
that Jerry Jones has kept Jason Garrett
around for 10 years he believes in this
guy even when a lot of the Cowboys fans
don't and so he wants to see what he can
do finishing out the season almost no
matter what what was your reaction to
Freddy kitchens wearing the Pittsburgh
started a t-shirt well I think just like
most people that looked at that it was a
bad look in 10 days removed almost from
one of the ugliest on-field incidents
that we've seen in recent memory Indiana
fell to kind of make light of a
situation like that and potentially
throw some fuel on the fire for the
Steelers game I just think it was
unnecessary and as a head coach I think
it's important for you to understand the
gravity of even the smallest details
when you're in that position of
responsibility you know Freddie's a
first time head coach his first time as
an offensive coordinator was last season
and until that position he was a tight
ends and a running backs coach and doing
stuff like that doesn't really move the
needle but one year in that head
coaching position I think just
understanding the gravity of every
little thing that you do and every move
you
make is important when you're a head
coach and it was just a bad look do you
remember all the quarterbacks you
blocked for how many quarterbacks do you
think played while you were playing with
the Cleveland Browns I think the number
was like 22 or 23 depending on if you
consider starters or just guys that had
to come in and fill in and release
everybody everybody I think it was like
23 oh my god my clothes I I don't know I
was just curious about you know I could
I can find that out
you remember all your head coaches right
I do I remember I think I had 6 head
coaches and 9 offensive coordinators I
think that was the basic 69 that I and
they wonder why it didn't work in
Cleveland and then you look at the
stability of some of these others you
know teams you know you look at New
England you go 20 years you've had a
coach and a quarterback together and
here you are having a different coach
you know almost every year every other
year yeah I never had a coach for more
than two seasons but I think that's why
you see these franchises that have
stability are so good at replacing guys
looking up in New England
obviously Brady is a big part of in
Belichick but when you're consistently
teaching the same message the same
technique to the same systems from year
to year the expectations are understood
when you walk in that building and they
don't really care if you're a rookie or
if you're a six year guy that they just
signed up everybody that is surrounding
you from the players and the coaches
that have done there they know what the
expectations are and so it's easy to
fall in line and it's easy to fall into
that winning culture where when you're
constantly changing things you're just
trying to get people on the same page
almost the first year as a head coach
and you're lucky to be able to teach
second and third grade concepts by the
end of the season whereas when you're in
the Patriots you're teaching graduate
level stuff almost the entire year
Paulie would you run down all of Joe
Thomas's starting quarterback I don't
know if we have time I got throw out a
few Derick Anderson Charlie Frey Brady
Quinn Ken Dorsey Bruce Krakowski
Colt McCoy Jake Delhomme Seneca Wallace
Thad Lewis Brandon Weeden Jason Campbell
Brian Hoyer Johnny Manziel Connor Shaw
Austin Davis Josh McCown Robert Griffin
the third Cody Kessler DeSean Kaiser
Kevin Hogan who was the best quarterback
he played with I think Derrick Anderson
had the best season he was a pro ball or
my rookie season and I think he probably
ended up having the best career I would
say maybe potentially because you know a
few good years been releasing Carolina's
there you know the one full year and
Cleveland are there any of these
quarterbacks
on your Christmas card list oh yeah I've
got great relationships with a lot of
them you know just because we didn't
have great success doesn't mean I
couldn't respect them as people and
players and have a good time with them
off the field like Brandon Weeden does
he get a Christmas card he's still on
that you know when you go to Shutterfly
and you just print out the address label
it great to catch up with you have fun
tonight Joe we appreciate your time as
always
again that's Joe Thomas NFL Network
analyst for more Dan Patrick show tune
in to audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
streamed for free on BR Live or download
the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]